To begin with, let's look at the engineering aspects of this project.
So when we're talking about blueprint class and C++ classes,
you can think of blueprint as the easy way to prototype something.
You can get a lot of visual feedback very quickly.
You can create rapid prototypes and it can feel like there's a better connection
to other subsystems and tools because of the visual nature of it.
If you use in material editors, animation graphs,
any other kind of subsystem of Unreal Engine,
you can get a more visual representation and therefore a better connection
in some instances to the tools inside of Unreal Engine.
It also has its own component editor window, so you can very quickly see
and debug things that are going on in your blueprinting.
Blueprinting is essentially C++ in a visual wrapper, though.
So C++ can be faster because it's a lower level state.
And this can even be up up to 10 to 30 times faster than a blueprint script.
So again, it depends on the projects that you want to create.
It depends on the goals of the project.
But if you want a really performant optimized project,
maybe C++ is the route to go.
And of course, it doesn't have to be one or the other.
You can build some lower level language in your projects in C++
and then build out some blueprint scripting on top of that.
There's no kind of hard defined clear rule there.
So C++, you have more functions available to you.
It's better for online replication and processing any kind of math based loops.
And it's also just a low level language there.
When we think about a game mode in relation to HMI,
you can think about the game mode as a singleton in that
it can be accessed by any class.
It holds data.
It can be very easily accessed across the project.
You can also store information in the game mode, which is super helpful,
especially if you're wanting to set certain parameters
and have those values remembered.
It will only exist as long as the level is open.
So when you begin a session in your project, you can store data in there.
You can reuse it in other places.
However, when the level is closed, the game mode will go away.
So if you're wanting to store long term data,
there is a concept called game instance and also save states.
So you can definitely dig into those if you want to maybe save some settings
close down the session, open that session up with those remembered variables.
You'd want to use a game instance and save states there.
Today, we'll be looking at setting up a controller,
which you can see has been edited here, a menu controller.
And you'll see that it's been edited by these little yellow icons.
Whenever you see this, it means the default state has been changed
inside of Unreal Engine.
So we're mainly looking at a controller today.
You'll see that the pawn class has been removed.
And that's just because we don't actually need a physical representation
of a pawn in today's course.
So sometimes it's just easier to remove that.
So there's no crossed wires of communication.
When we are talking about this controller that we're setting up,
you can think of a controller in terms of the digital representation of the user.
The user will possess a pawn, but the controller has all of the input.
So every touch or click that you use to input some kind of action
into the project, that will all be done on the controller.
So the controller will decide the method of input,
whether it be on the mouse or the touch screen on the cursor,
any kind of peripheral that's being used,
the controller will decide how to interact with the project.
So in a HMI controller can be used to change the interaction modes,
manage information.
So in a control, you also have these mouse interface settings.
So we can show the mouse cursor if it's off by default,
we can enable click events.
We can enable click events and that helps you interact with the levels in your project.
When we are thinking about a pawn in relation to HMI,
the pawns usually represent some kind of visual avatar.
It's the user's kind of digital form here and it's a pseudo singleton.
HMI is generally like any kind of visible pawn.
We generally just use it to possess a camera,
to see some of the visual elements in the scene.
But if no visible element is needed, then you don't need to have it move or manipulate anything.
So in a standard HMI game mode, HMI pawn class will be set to none,
as we saw in the previous slide there.
We can enable a few plugins for our project today.
Batches in code slash data can be enabled or disabled through the plugins window.
And when we're looking at sensor data with Unreal,
Canbus is a redundant safety critical protocol that provides information from the sensors around the car.
So you're provided with a file of what messages contain,
and then you get them fed constantly at a specific rate.
When a message content changes, then you get a different message,
but they're repeatedly at the same rate.
So car sensors provide only partial HMI info and Canbus isn't used for everything,
which is why we have a service layer that provides all the information to the UI.
So we tend to avoid direct Canbus connection to Unreal Engine because it's not useful in production.
You can find a tutorial on how to do this on the case electronics dot com site,
which is Canbus simple intro tutorial.
And that's the CSS electronics dot com website.
So we can initiate the proxy objects from the game instance
and just make sure they're available before begin play of everything else.
Otherwise, you'll have objects trying to act on null objects that aren't created yet.
You may use MQTT, but you'd still need to write all the Unreal Engine
C++ code and the service side code to have a complete solution.
But the API gear can generate all that code
and it's the OEMs don't truly factor into the cost of decisions like that.
But hopefully that's a good overview of sensor data with Unreal.